hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I don't know if you noticed but in the
background of my Galaxy s7
impressions video that ezel TV back
there yeah that is the crazy super
expensive samsung s9 TV from CES two
years ago so that was kind of the
inspiration for coming back to this
topic of ridiculously overpriced stuff
so we had top 5 most expensive tech part
1 this is going to be 5 more of the
worst deals in tech number one hard
drives but not just normal everyday hard
drives those actually tend to be a
pretty good deal but the ones that cost
more and claim to be super fast like the
SuperSpeed hard drives the 10,000 rpm
hard drives at this point in 2016 the
only real reason to go with a hard drive
over a solid-state drive is if you need
more storage for the price hard drives
tend to be slower but also way cheaper
for the same amount of storage than an
SSD except for the SuperSpeed drives
this is a Velociraptor 10,000 rpm one
terabyte drive before SSDs these are
actually a really cool idea but now
they're literally the worst of both
worlds they're still slower in most read
and write speed than any SSD but they're
also less durable and less reliable than
any SSD and they don't match the density
of a regular larger three and a half
inch hard drive that there's so much
more expensive than so really just make
up your mind you can just get a big slow
hard drive or really fast SSD sorry for
going on so long about hard drives so
number two is the luxury smartphone that
I'm not even sure if anyone actually
buys right so I'm going to go down a
list of specs of a smart phone and you
can just go ahead and tell me roughly
what you think it should cost you know
high end mid range whatever you think
let me know ok ready
Snapdragon 801 chip 3 gigabytes of RAM
Android 4.4 KitKat a 5-inch 1080p IPS
display 20 megapixel camera $6,000 now
I'm no smartphone expert or anything but
I've owned a few smart phones in my day
and I can definitely say that that one
is overpriced by a lot I was going to
say it's kind of like the the beats by
dre of smartphones but it's worse than
that really the mark-up is even more
insane so their justification or at
their selling point
he actually is exactly this
uncompromising quality in every detail
down to the stitching and vibrant color
choices to help our devices and users
stand out from a sea of too familiar
phones so when you're too cool for the
normal phones apparently I know everyone
likes luxury and everyone likes limited
edition stuff but a smartphone is
actually a tool that you have to use
every day it's not like some ornament
that you just put up on a shelf and tell
stories about now if you don't use your
smartphone every day and it is an
ornament then sure by all means put it
up on a shelf talk about it don't
actually use it but if you use your
smartphone everyday like a tool like
most people do then avoid anything with
the name virtu on it number three the
Apple watch Edition this kind of falls
into the same category as smart phones I
had a harder time putting this one on my
list because it is actually materially
pretty valuable but you're gonna have to
hear me out here the Apple watch is
already pretty expensive for a smart
watch right comes in anywhere from 350
bucks all the way up to you know 1,100
1,200 bucks so it's pretty high-end you
ever watch that TV show with 2 Chainz
where they review the most expensive
stuff in the world and I had that one
episode with the world's most expensive
ice cream do you remember how they made
just simple ice cream end up a thousand
bucks they literally just added pure
gold to apparently gold is edible and
the ice cream just got that much more
expensive BAM Apple watch edition pure
gold casing seventeen thousand dollars
the thing is it's still a piece of tech
and it's a first gen Apple product no
less so you know the next generation one
is going to be a lot better the number
one suggested Google search result for
Apple watch is Apple watch 2 there's
going to be new Apple watch in a couple
months with some new features better
performance better battery life better
build quality better everything you
played yourself number four is the crazy
expensive HDMI cables I'm going back to
those again I did go over them a bit in
the first video but I'm just really
entertained at this point by how many
different ways they're coming up with
now to try to charge a couple hundred
dollars for cable unique silver and gold
contacts with innovative HD grip for
great connection carbon fiber plug for
high-tech elegance we twisted the wires
a little bit for exquisite sound
video the silver somehow illuminates the
fine details yeah okay alright number
five last but not least in the most
overpriced tech is going to go to the
Sennheiser Orpheus $50,000 headphones
they're crazy well presented the marble
and glass casing are dope
the tube amp lighting up is awesome and
it presents itself to this awesome
experience but they only sound like
20,000 bucks max Sennheiser let's be
real I mean I love you guys I love sine
Iser but let's be real so there you have
it that's your most overpriced tech in
the second episode honorable mentions I
got to go with the Panasonic 4k Toughpad
it's a 4k tablet in more than one way
the pono player a super high resolution
dedicated music player for 400 bucks
just think about that one and this
$15,000 charging cable
i reaiiy have no idea how that happened
if you have any other ideas for other
ridiculously overpriced tech stuff feel
free to leave that in the comments
section right below you can click on any
of the ones I talked about in this video
if you want to ruin your Amazon
suggested recommendations forever
and that's pretty much it I'm out of
here thanks for watching I'll talk to
you guys the next one peace